Hey, so glad you're here. This is day 38.
We are almost to the end of our 40 days of holiness.
Today, we're talking about holiness and the emotions.
Yesterday we said that sometimes emotions can feel like our enemy because
we frequently have to act against our emotions, right?
Like I don't feel like getting up, but I have to act against them.
And we talked about, there's got to be a way to commit to Christ
and then enjoy and cultivate the right emotions.
How do we do that? So today, I want to talk to you about that.
I went through a time in my life, around college age, where I was
really kind of anti-emotion. I thought that emotions were my
enemies because I frequently had to act against them.
And I concluded that I was the victim of my emotions.
But that wasn't really true. And let me see if I can
explain to you why that is. Let me use a song to
do it with, all right? There's a song that says, "I feel
like traveling on."
And I felt like that was such a stupid song because it's like, "I
feel like traveling on." Come on, man.
I travel on even when I don't feel like it.
Which is true, right? Do you hear how emotions can be my
enemy? And so I conclude that I had to
decide that emotions are my enemy, and I'll be the victim if I'm not
careful, so I've got to reject emotion. Right?
But I found something as I was meditating on it years later.
I found that I
actually didn't have to be that way because there's another part
to that song. You know what the other part is?
"My heavenly home is bright and fair.
I feel like traveling on." Right?
"Nor pain nor death can enter there.
I feel like traveling on.
Its glittering towers, the sun outshine.
That heavenly mansion shall be mine.
I feel like traveling on." Now,
what that song is actually doing
is using
this right here.
It is taking facts, objectively true facts,
processing them through the imagination,
and allowing that imagination to create the right feelings in us.
This word here then becomes extremely,
extremely important. Someday I'm going to write
a book and do a video course called Holy Imagination,
talking about how to capture the imagination, to
create the proper feelings in your heart, and to allow you to
experience and cultivate the right emotions about
God and his reality. So these facts,
if you process "My heavenly home is bright and fair," and if you
close your eyes and you see that, and you see
the beauty of it, and the excellence of it, and the glory
of it. And you feel the thrill, and you smell and feel
the wind, and you taste the food, and imagine all
is well, and everything is perfect.
It doesn't take very long. If you do a good job, it doesn't take very long before
your imagination produces the right feelings.
Let me tell you when I discovered this.
I discovered it when I had little kids.
And they were in their beds, and they would cry out in
the middle of the night with a bad dream,
right? So I would go in there, and I started teaching them how
to recapture their thoughts
using imagination. How to recapture their thoughts and get rid of the
negative anxiety-filled emotions and replace them with ones
of peace that facilitated the kind of action I wanted, which was for
them to go to sleep.
Now,
in that moment, what I would do is I would say, "I want you to think of something
right now."
Now, it wasn't about, "Stop that. There's no such thing as monsters. Cut it out.
There's no such thing as a
burglar in our house. Stop feeling those emotions," was not the solution.
Am I making sense to you?
That was not the solution. The solution was to
focus their minds on some other reality that was better,
some other facts.
And I said, "I want you to think about right now, I want you to close your eyes,
and I want you to see
Silver Dollar City in Branson," where we were at on vacation.
"And I want you to think about it. Do you hear the music from that place
over there, the one side where the music is coming from, where that little band is
playing? And they're playing the fiddle, and it's fast, and do you
smell the funnel cakes that are cooking over there
on the other side? And I want you to close your eyes, and I want you to see our
whole family walking together, and we're laughing and having
fun, and we're heading down to go on one of your favorite rides.
Which ride do you think it is?" Do you see what I'm doing?
What I'm doing is I'm creating in them a
clear imaged picture of something that really is true.
They're not there right now, but it's true. It's real.
And they've been there before, and they've had a taste of it before, and I
want them to experience it over again
in the power of their imagination
so that emotional results happen.
I hope you can
see this. You say, "Well, that's just New Age gobbledygook." No, it's not.
Why do you think God gave you metaphors like water of
life?
Why do you think that's
true?
Why do you think it is that God said, "I am your strong tower"?
Why do you think he did that? Because there were people who knew
what it was to run from the wild animal, and if I can just
get to the tower
and slam the door behind me.
The thick stones and the bulwark of that tower will protect me from
everything that might
do me harm.
Why do you think that the Lord has given us all of these metaphors, that he
is a mother hen who gathers us under his wings?
Why do you think that he has given us metaphors like he is our shield
and our sword? Why do you think he says that the Lord is a mighty
warrior?
You know why? He wants to capture your imagination because he knows
if you see him like that and as he really is,
your emotions will become what they ought to be.
The truth is that if you can see, if you can image
well in your mind what God is and who he is,
your emotions can become the friend of your holiness.
They can. And
this makes me incredibly excited because I know it's true.
I have experienced it myself. I have taught others how to
do that, and I want you to commit your way to the
Lord,
to commit to him as the bedrock, whether your feelings are
there or not. However long it takes you to create them, you are
committed to God as the bedrock of your holiness.
But then build on top of that an imagination that grabs a
hold of the truth about God so keenly and holds
it in the imaging power of your mind so
intensely that you can see it, and out of it flows the
feelings that you ought to have about God.
You ought to feel about him as he really, really is.
Now, if you can learn to do this, okay, it's a strategy, but I would encourage you
to sit down and take time daily to
get yourself into a happy frame of mind about who God is. All right?
If you'll do that, your emotions will be the friend of your
holiness and not their enemy.
God bless you. I'll talk to you tomorrow.